hello and welcome to this final week of
this course as well as to the final week
of this sequence of five courses in the
deep learning specialization you're
nearly at the finish line in this week
you hear about sequences sequence models
which are useful for everything from
machine translation to speech
recognition the start of the basic
models and then later this week you hear
about beam search the attention model
and we'll wrap up the discussion of
models for audio data like speech let's
get started let's say you want to input
a French sentence like John vesicular
freak and September and you want to
translate it to the English sentence
Jane is visiting Africa in September as
usual let's use X 1 through X in this
case 5 to represent the words in the
input sequence and we'll use y1 through
y 6 to represent the words in the output
sequence so how can you train a neural
network to input the sequence X and
output the sequence Y well here's
something you could do and the ideas I'm
about to present our mainly from these
two papers due to the Asafa or even
yells and Kotler and that one by
Jonghyun Chobot then Marienburg kepler
golf Sara Dmitry bother Neil veggie
burgers Holger strengthen your ginger
first let's have a network which we're
gonna call the encoder Network be built
as a RNN and this could be a gr you are
now STM feed in d input french words one
word at a time and after ingesting the
input sequence d RNN then outputs a
vector that represents the input
sentence after that you can build a
decoder network which you might draw
here which takes as input the encoding
output by the encode the network shown
in black on the left and then
can be trained to output the translation
one word at a time until eventually it
opens dia say the end of sequence and
the sentence token upon which the
decoder stops and as usual we could take
the generated tokens and feed them to
the Knicks
so the fated states in the sequence like
we're doing before when synthesizing
text using the language model one of the
most remarkable recent results in deep
learning is that this model works
given enough pairs of French and English
sentences if you train a model to input
a French sentence and output the
corresponding English translation this
won't actually work decently well and
this model simply uses an encoding
network whose job it is to find an
encoding of the input French sentence
and then use a decoder network to then
generate the corresponding English
translation and architecture very
similar to this also works for image
captioning so given an image like the
one shown here maybe you wanted to be
captions automatically as a cat sitting
on the chair so how do you train in your
network to input an image and output a
caption like that phrase up there here's
what you can do from the earlier course
on confidence you've seen how you can
input an image into a convolutional
network maybe a pre trained Alex net and
have that learn and encoding or learn a
set of features of the input image so
this is actually the Alex net
architecture and if we get rid of this
final softmax unit the pre-trained alex
net can give you a 4096 dimensional
feature vector or for each to represent
this picture of a cat and so this free
trained network can be the encoder
network for the image and you now have a
four thousand four thousand
ninety-six dimensional vector that
represents the image you can then take
this and feed it to an RNN whose job it
is to generate the caption one word at a
time so similar to what we saw with
machine translation translating from
French to English you can now input a
beaker vector describing the input and
then have it generate an output sequence
or output set of words one word at a
time
and this actually works pretty well for
image captioning especially the caption
want to generate is not too long as far
as I know this model this type of model
was first proposed by Chinua Malaysia Yi
Jung Yonghwa joo hyung-hwan
and alan zero although it turns out
there are multiple groups coming out
with very similar models independently
and at about the same time so two other
groups that had done very similar work
at about the same time and I think
independently of mouthal were all your
videos exams Atocha of Sammy banjo and
Dmitri Iran as well as our chica Posse
and David Lee so you've now seen how a
basic sequence the sequence model works
or how a basic image the sequence or
image captioning model works but there
are some differences between how you
would run a model like this to generate
the sequence compared to how you were
synthesizing novel text using a language
model one of the key differences is you
don't want a randomly chosen translation
you maybe want the most likely
translation you don't want the randomly
chosen caption maybe not but you might
want the best caption the most likely
caption so let's see in the next video
how you go about generating that